trying to make it better for the
chargers multiple reports indicate that
anthony lynn's fate won't be determined
until after the season a risky endeavor
when so many teams already are looking
for coaches unless the chargers know
exactly who they're going to go after
and exactly who they're going to get or
they have the confidence that they've
got one of the most attractive openings
and they do with the presence of justin
herbert i'm assuming that any coach that
goes there will be happy to have justin
herbert as his quarterback we've seen
some trojan horse approaches in the past
like when josh mcdaniels became the
coach of the broncos and his first order
of business was to run off jay cutler i
doubt that mcdaniels led with that
concept when he interviewed for the job
but herbert has shown that he's one of
the best things the team has going
and at this point based on the way they
lost yesterday
i can't imagine a coaching change not
coming for the chargers they're trying
to win hearts minds and wallets in los
angeles you don't do it with a coach
that that can't win
close games got blown off the field
yesterday with multiple special teams
gaps where you don't have enough guys on
the field or too many guys on the field
i mean that part should be very
mechanical and simple everyone should
know
whether or not they're on the punt team
or the kickoff team or this team or that
team there shouldn't be any ambiguity
going into a game so it's not good i
like anthony lynn
i i
i feel bad that it's happening this way
but
it's two straight years of of under
achievement and with promise in the form
of justin herbert i think that's a
recipe for disaster for the coach who
isn't getting it done because that's the
perfect time to lure a top coach to come
take over your team
mike everybody likes mike lynn and i i
think that's important to know you know
it talks about
chargers ownership and in front office
loves him we all love him everybody
anybody who's ever met anthony lynn
loves anthony lynn but it doesn't change
the fact that two weeks ago it was a
clock management issue which has been an
ongoing problem from anthony land and
then this past week it was the special
teams problems as you mentioned multiple
problems on special teams and his press
conference is going on right now and he
just said he's thinking about taking
over special teams what's really too
late for that i i think the decision has
been
i don't know if the decision has been
made but i think it's been made probably
for the organization about what they do
after the season
because you're right they haven't won
enough games with justin herbert with
with how he's played and
they should have won more and when you
look at some of the things that have
happened in the ways they have lost they
should have more wins than what they
have and since they were 12-4 in 2018
they're 8 and 20. they just haven't
gotten it done in his four seasons 29
and 31 overall and that includes that 12
and four season so he's had enough time
to get this done couldn't get it done
with philip rivers and now is not
getting it done with justin herbert and
mike you hate a young quarterback to
keep giving him and we saw what baker
mayfield keep giving him head coaches
and offensive coordinators and
quarterback coaches and changing the
system that's not good for a young
quarterback but i don't know that you
have a choice except to move on from
anthony lynn and this staff after this
season
and here's something to keep in mind and
i'm not suggesting it's going to happen
but when you look at the last 20 years
in the nfl
john gruden essentially traded by the
raiders to the buccaneers although it's
not a classic trade the coach has a very
direct say in whether or not he's going
to leave one team to coach another herm
edwards when he went from the jets to
the chief stick for meal kind of he had
retired from the rams and then went to
the chiefs
uh jim harbaugh almost traded from the
49ers to the browns several years ago
it's amazing to me that more teams don't
explore the possibility of approaching a
team who has a coach under contract
reaching a deal on what the compensation
would be and then talking to the coach
about coming to take over but the
chargers are in position if they want i
i just it seems to me and i don't know
if there's a gentleman's agreement or
what shireen
but
i feel like not enough teams
take seriously enough the possibility of
targeting a coach who's currently with
another team and having a quarterback
like justin herbert around
in theory should allow you to be able to
at least try that if that's what you
want to do
well and we just talked about doug
peterson right and how many times can
you hire a super bowl winning coach and
that he would be the perfect guy even if
the eagles decide not to get rid of him
or he decides not to leave at the end of
the season that's a guy you could go get
who i think would be perfect for justin
herbert i this guy can coach i mean
we've seen it we saw the philly special
we saw all those plays he called he won
a super bowl with nick foles this guy's
really good so i agree with you that
that's
perhaps a way to go for a team
especially one that has a young
quarterback that can benefit from a guy
who's done it who's won it who's had
quarterbacks that he's made better he
hasn't done it with carson wentz for
whatever reason but maybe that's more on
wince than it is on peterson
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports